[Applause]
this is a remarkable achievement what
you're seeing here is the last photon
orbit what you are seeing is evidence of
an event horizon by laying a ruler
across this black hole
we now have visual evidence for a black
hole we now know that a black hole that
weighs six point five billion times what
our Sun does exist in the center of m87
and this is the strongest evidence that
we have to date for the existence of
black holes and it is also consistent
the shape of this shadow to the
precision of our measurements with
Einstein's predictions the bright patch
in the South you see tells us that
material moving around the black hole is
moving at light speeds which is also
consistent with our simulations and
predictions and this image forges a
clear link now between supermassive
black holes and the engines of bright
galaxies we now know clearly that black
holes drive large-scale structure in the
universe from their home in these
galaxies and we now have an entirely new
way of studying general relativity and
black holes that we never had before and
as with all great discoveries this is
just the beginning so imaging a black
hole doesn't come easily I can tell you
that from personal experience as can
many people here in the audience